qu'est-ce qui se passe il va vraiment
des charges est ici et qui t'a appris à
conduire en tulle et de traces
je t'en supplie cheryl le regarde pas
d'or c'est un ouf vous parlez comme sa
levée vous fait ça venez nous dire enfin
vraiment débat de faire son affaire pour
rossi va te faire [ __ ]
chérie c'est bon c'est bon tu l'as bien
bouché là-haut qu'est ce qui t'arrive
seul peu stressée à l'idée de revoir
tout le monde doit avec nos amis
la semaine dernière on était encore de
vrais adultes retour à nos 19 ans on va
se retrouver m c'est que tu aime
beaucoup tes amis mais à chaque fois que
tu les vois vous transformer en langue
de [ __ ] site ou bien de félix d'année ça
crée des liens on a 20 ans de rancoeur
et de reproches à se faire on peut tous
exploser d'apt c'est toujours la compet
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas obligé de crier à chaque
fois que vous coupez la balle je suis
tellement concentré que je m'entends pas
on dirait que vous êtes en train de
chier suis là depuis dix minutes et vous
avez déjà chier 300 fois je fais pas ce
bruit là quand je pose une peche
j'aime la big g seulement parfois je me
demande ce qu'il arriverait si tout
était chamboulé et que je doive tout
recommencer ça n'a rien à voir avec la
liaison
stupide amourettes de fac qui a duré
longtemps pourquoi tu t'obstines appeler
ça une ligne et sans parce que vous
coucher ensemble alors que vous êtes
marié avec d'autres genres
[Musique]
paulo ce sont des diables grosse suceurs
de but
alors vous allez faire barde en effet
moi j'étais princeton
ah oui comment fais tu pour coucher avec
des femmes qui en la moitié du temps là
j'ai l'impression d'avoir perdu mon âme
on met des gens bien ouais ce soir c'est
moi au moins je suis désolé mais on est
vraiment des mauvaises personnes des
mauvaises personnes
vois-tu oui ou non avoir un enfant sur
sérieux
tu es le genre de personne qui ne peut
pas ne pas donner un sens à sa vie
[Musique]
et à deux choses importantes dans ce
monde les pecs et les fesses il a tout
ce qu'il faut
[Musique]
je veux que vous sachiez qu'après avoir
longuement discuté avec maxime soir j'ai
décidé de venir et d'essayer de vous
appréciez ça c'est faisable
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous faites les gars on
est là
[Musique]